what's going on there reject nation greg
and john here today
after the craziness of the loki episode
4
episode from yesterday you better gonna
keep the tradition going
with e.a voss's new rockstars loki
episode 4 breakdown there's a lot to
uncover let's just swing into
action
[Music]
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of loki
episode 4 the
nexus event in which loki lovin himself
may save the multiverse from robot
puppets and locators
let's break down this episode shot by
shot for all the easter eggs and visual
clues that you might have overlooked to
figure out what the hell with one l is
going
on and a reminder that the best way to
support us here at new rockstars is to
get yourself some great
merch using this limited edition
time shirt that i will be wearing in
every video
so this episode opens on asgard from
sylvie's timeline the opening shot rises
up behind the green hills that enclosed
the kingdom
a reversal of the past thor centric
establishing shots of asgard that
approached from the bypross gate because
for sovie asgard wasn't a hometown that
she returned to after battle to revel in
glory
it was a rustic hearth that she dreamed
of those adventures from
she plays with toys but valkyrie flies
over defeats the dragon
and saves out like thor admitted in
ragnarok sylvie's fan crush was valkyrie
riding her pegasus now the dragon may be
the muspelheim dragon that thor slayed
in ragnarok's opening she also has a
wolf
perhaps fenris hellas wolf steed and
this viking boat actually another of
which can be seen over by the seat in
the
background
now the tva comes in and arrests her for
no apparent reason
other than she's a loki but perhaps
since sylvie sees herself in a heroic
light that could be what causes the tva
or the mystery figure actually
controlling the tva to
see her as a potential threat because
that person wants loki's to be the bad
guy and die prematurely
now this squad is led by red slayer
before she became a judge
now hunter a23 which is probably a
reference to avengers 23 in 1963
the first comic appearance of ravona
rinslayer
[Applause]
[Music]
but she rebuffs him so you know he moves
to destroy your home which fellas is not
the response to no
i really do love it whenever new
rockstars is able to
accurately pinpoint the references to
the comic books so some a lot of times
we could just chalk up
like oh this number is probably this
comic reference but that is way too
specific
of a comic to completely disregard that
you know that's an intentional
production design choice
hell yeah already loving it already
loving it
you're ready to type that comment eric
voss says anything real rejects oh
greg clapton sorry but they're awesome
the writers choosing ravona rinslayer as
opposed to
any tva judge from the comics feels like
it could be a deliberate move to
introduce kang into the mcu
and referencing the specific comic issue
where ravana was introduced and that
relationship was front and center
seems like a pretty big hint toward that
perhaps
the one pulling the strings of the tva
he's the one who used his time travel
abilities to create this bureaucracy
that could manipulate time in a very
specific way
and now sees all loki variants who
survive as chaotic nexus beans who
destabilize his perfect timeline i mean
now that the timekeepers are revealed to
be
android puppets controlled by a mystery
man behind the curtain and richard
grant is playing a different character
that leaves a vacuum for a big bad light
kang
to appear ahead of jonathan major's
portrayal of him in quantum media though
in interviews majors claims to have no
idea what we're talking about so we'll
see
let's remember that jonathan majors also
denied even playing king the conqueror
before it was officially announced it
was like a little bit before it was
officially announced so he's definitely
going to be in loki
yeah i'm not saying it's a def saying
can't really trust these guys
now we never see what happens with the
figurines silvia was playing with they
don't get erased with a reset charge so
maybe they were collected by rentslayer
for her creepy collection of trophies
i mean kang's kingdom of chronopolis
which could be that city in the quantum
realm
is in the comics similarly made up of
architectural relics of trophies from
histories kang has conquered so young
sylvie goes through the booking process
from a lower and much scarier vantage
point she notices the four-all-time
always tva seal that loki walks right
over in the pilot her transfer stack is
much shorter than loki's since you know
she's much younger and has spoken much
less
but notice does not yet feature his
beloved cat and silvie doesn't like look
down to see any cat in the corner so
that cat might have been a more recent
acquisition and by the way i hope the
cat's name is strowdinger because that
would be awesome
the girl is scanned to determine she is
not a robot
which since the timekeepers are androids
might actually be to prevent other
robots from entering the tva and
detecting that secret because you know
i'm bot phobic and i ignorantly assume
all robots know each other red slayer
meets with the timekeepers who are
arranged much like the goofy future
leaders and floating seats and bill and
teddy yeah you nailed it that's exactly
what you said
that's exactly what you said to someone
less squared
yet still excellent but behind them is
this red
glowing symbol that looks similar at
least to the runes that agatha and wanda
used to mark a magical boundary to
prevent others
magic within that boundary like perhaps
similar sorcery was used by whoever
built the tva to keep
once again to a close-up of the face of
the central time keeper the one who's
head by the end of this episode will be
cut off
now mobius wants to talk to c20 but
rentslayer says dad
obvious what how
oh owen wilson may not get to say wow in
the series but he does get a solid
how wow loki and sylvie sit on the
doomed lamentus one
i'm sorry i remember asgard
yeah i like how that meteor whizzes like
a bullet through sylvie's head at the
moment she cracks to
open up to loki about her past and
sylvie says the tva arrested her because
she's a source of chaos
the universe wants to break free so it
manifests chaos
like me being born the goddess of
mischief and she may be right she did
really nothing to spawn a nexus event
she was just targeted because someone
fears all loki's who don't die
prematurely
we may lose fascinating sometimes
painfully
but we don't die we survive
that's so true because even by the final
moments of this episode
loki dies it survives it just keeps
happening and it's clear that a bunch of
other loki's can prove this part too
now back at the tv the screen shows
wrightville pennsylvania january 6
1832 that's referring to a bridge over
the susquehanna river in 1832 that
collapsed due to ice and flooding then
mag the planet where peter quill
recovered the power stone and guardians
of the galaxy revisited an end game
which was a planet that used to be
covered by vast oceans until the water
receded
perhaps due to some environmental
catastrophe now above those are mentions
of
sakaar that's the trash plan of throat
ragnarok and alberta canada the province
containing calgary
site of one of the worst catastrophes in
the year 1970 the birth of this piece of
[ __ ]
and i am a very very proud wacko and
later on
above you can read unidentified planet
interesting since we know that tva has
seen
all of historical existence and by the
end of that there are still some planets
that remain unidentified
that is interesting because sylvie knew
lamentis won the second they were there
yeah she was like lamenting like
sylvie knows it but they realize what
you've done but yet the tva
considers it an unidentified planet yeah
that's really fascinating maybe it's
only the moon that was notable to them
and then barcelona spain again and then
a bit later after barcelona there's
aladon
referring to aladon prime a decimated
planet that the cree
army retreated to in the annihilation
conquest comics and then after that
lima peru now we get this gnarly point
of view of the shot from the planet
crashing toward lamented one as it
breaks apart
reminds me of the point of view shots
from the asteroid in armageddon
it's crazy but to be honest they gave us
some really fun stuff to look at
so it is loki and sylvie's connection
that leads to this
intensely powerful branch the nexus
event of this title it is so powerful
that it defied the apocalypse that
should have prevented this branch from
forming
meaning that these two free surviving
loki's connecting
falling for each other as opposed to
killing each other represents the
greatest threat to the person behind the
timekeepers and their sacred timeline
essentially this is like
but they get captured and movies throws
loki through this red
door that's outlined in the same kind of
neon glow as the timekeeper's rune
so perhaps it represents a different
kind of inner tva magic in this case
it's this time
cell a looped memory torture prison kind
of like something you'd see in black
mirror but jamie alexander returns as
lady siff you conniving craven pathetic
worm you did this what
i hope you know you deserve to be alone
and you always will be
now sift did not die with the warriors 3
in ragnarok and she is expected to
return in thor 11th
under loki cutting sif's hair is
actually from norse mythology in which
loki cut off sif's hair and to make up
for it went to nidalee where the dwarves
crafted her new hair from gold
i love that crafting for the gods all
kinds of things like mjolnir
what a great way to include actual like
norse mythology
absolutely i love how that they've done
that with them i mean it's within the
comics themselves i'll be real with you
i know more about the marvel
norse mythology than i do actually
and yet you appreciate that they're
doing the actual norse mythology
justice even though you only really
invested in it due to its being
now i love how you can hear the loop
track resetting each time
because it was just a bit of fun
[Music]
and while we're talking about the sound
mix of the scene each of sif's
successive hits get louder and louder on
each pass to convey that increasing pain
level on loki
[Music]
so moebius tells people
referring to the imperialist cree from
captain marvel they also might have
shown up in that miss minutes animation
titans could refer to the people of
titan that's thanos's home world
genealogically thanos is an eternal with
a deviant gene
though maybe once they all relocated to
titan they just went by the name titans
and vampires acknowledges the existence
of marvel vampires soon to be explored
in titles like blade
actually vampires were brought up
previously in thor ragnarok want to use
a big wooden fork
no yeah not really useful unless you're
fighting off three vampires that were
huddled together
silly is being interrogated in time
theater 47 could be a nod to marvel what
if 47
in which loki takes the worst hammer i
only bring it up because we actually see
a version of loki with a version of
mjolnir in the post-credits scene
what did that mean that loki is worthy i
don't know what happens to that comic
specifically but if that loki has milner
if he just took it unless
he's like such a he's such a variant
that he is actually the one who became
thor this loki's the one who was the one
bestowed and became worthy enough
because they're talking about how
the lookies are meant to be bad so what
if that looks yeah
it's meant to be good and so that's why
he's a variant
that version you know that's a good
theory i think that's really solid dude
either that or he tricked the hammer
now in loki's interrogation room notice
the overhead lights how when they first
come back into it they shift downward
this room might be part of one of the
spires that we've seen in the tva
exterior rotates
whatever the outside light sources the
camera work uses this lighting to really
great effect like when loki tells mobius
that he and all the tva employees
are variants so before this you had a
past
maybe you had a family a life
[Music]
a chetsky nice try
yeah notice how for a moment as mobis
considers this possibility the light of
truth
shines on his shoulders but then he
leans back forward and shadowed to
signal him blocking that notion oh how
cool what a great deal
overhead lights shift back upward in the
other direction and then as loki says
that mobius is lying to himself the
light behind mobius
shrinks back
now sees this poster that reads did you
get them all verified through deletion
with this big brother in mustangs
now i'm getting some howard stark vibes
from this guy but i'm thinking it could
be some veteran tva director
maybe he who remains who created the
timekeepers in the comics
or it could just be a tribute to like
how you know hosts such as vincent price
or from back there you know like they
look like it's a traditional sci-fi host
yeah yeah or just a big brother nod i
think it really is
no that's a character we're going to
meet
in rensselaer's office this music plays
[Music]
this is licinia the swan by composer
camille sansomes
played here though by clara rockmore
really the first maestro of the musical
instrument the theremin
i was wondering if they actually used it
beautiful beautifully loki director kate
herron said she played rockmore's
rendition of this song
in her pitch to direct this series and
that is why you can hear it really
so often throughout this show
damn dizzy and their virtue signaling
putting all this behind us
amen yeah his path here will lead to his
own pruning so it's a bit fitting that
he uses this religious affirmation
so red slayer adds to her trophies
sylvie's sword while moby switches their
temp pads and abruptly leaves
one drink i think i had two didn't i
mobius yeah mobius is plain drunk here
but being confused over how many drinks
he's had connects to when he did not
remember leaving ring stains on her
table
just saying he might not be the first or
only mobius out there nor the last
so sylvie reconstructs b15's memory i
looked happy
masaku so good she cries real tears
right the rain drops on your speaks
they're good i nod to the famous tears
and rain monologue
we've got it josh it was
facing a similar realization as
replicants that her memories give her
humanity that has been denied to her so
mobius confirms from rent slayer's temp
ad
that she prunes c20 as a cover-up so he
goes to tell loki
you can be whoever whatever you want to
be
even someone good i mean just in case
anyone ever told you different
and loki responds with this heartfelt
grin which sadly leads this moment where
mobius knows ravana is about to prune
him so he says where he would always
want to go
and wherever i had a life before the tva
came along
i knew i had a jet ski oh this is so
hard to
well considering loki got pruned to this
exile place it is possible doing this
could have unplugged mobius to his past
life jet skiing
i mean let's hope so we know from
trailer footage that this isn't the last
time we're going to see him
oh okay
that was like a weird sense of relief
because we didn't believe he actually
died
you know he said it like several times
in our reaction i mean marvel puts that
[ __ ] into their trailers yeah
i feel like they're expecting a large
part of their audience to also not
really
fully buy into it either yeah yeah they
are very careful with their trailers so
unless that's a deleted seed that they
threw in there which i don't believe
it is marvel already spoiled it
themselves because that moment of him
behind the wheel is not in
anything so anyone who watched the
trailer would notice that and there
could still be bigger surprises
to that yeah yeah so i wouldn't be like
upset they're like oh
voss you're ruining like a marvel room
you're ruined by calling attention to
the advertisement
that they put out to millions of people
to view it yeah
for the same amount of people who watch
loki to watch that too
notice how it ends with this digital zip
sound almost like someone being zipped
up in a time body bag
time bag in the elevator sylvia asks
what was my nexus event why did you
bring me in
i don't remember that little smirk it's
similar to what thanos said to wanda
maxim off an end game
you took everything you said
this is where you said too joe you're
three
percent against three for three
so on to the timekeeper's chamber it
looks like it was designed from m c
escher's relativity lithograph
looks very cool that's what i said
you love fcs sure
[Music]
the [ __ ] are these muppets i especially
love the lorax one
two have to fight
much like the great and powerful oz just
assigned to us that they're clearly
about to be revealed as a smoke screen
after the fight sylvie decapitates the
central timekeeper eliciting laughs
from the other two until they've shut
down like chucky cheese robots
fake mindless androids
i love how its mouth continues to twitch
like ash the android seven aliens
[Music]
the production design stays consistent
with the tva's 70s analog tech
but yes this confirms that the
timekeepers are not sacred deities and
much of what we heard in that missed
minutes welcome video was probably a lie
i hope that
uh because you know we see uh jonathan
majors in like lovecraft country i hope
that
kang uh is obsessed with daniel richards
is obsessed with uh just the 70s yeah
that was where he
he conquered earth is during the 70s i
want job
talking kang the conqueror ladies
robono wren slayer you were in charge of
the tva today
let me put it down for you how this
sacred timeline
he's always proceeded with some kind of
wawa guitar and like a
that's why i designed the tv it looks
that way i'm not saying that's how
jonathan major
sounds okay he's a fantastic actor whom
i love
he's creating watchmen aquaman the
upcoming matrix movie
oh yeah yeah handyman so good
trial the chicago seven it's called
satiri florence fishberg
but rather these were the artificial
creations of someone else now in the
comics that was he who remains the elder
tba agent at the end of all time but in
the comics they aren't like mindless
robots like this
they're really sentient beings with real
power who operate independently but some
believe these robots could be based on
the doom bots of dr doom or that he who
remains could be some other past loki
variant a king loki
or even that this is all automated
clockwork with no one at the helm but
miss minutes but i think based on ravana
being their advocate
a person who got promoted to judge
despite losing a variant in a courtroom
who now seems
okay with loki killing her off as if
someone who's been a prisoner in this
position
i think the chances are looking a bit
better that kang could be behind us all
and there's no chance i'll regret
theorizing that
it's not the same case as mephisto
because he's officially announced to be
coming in an up not too far away ant-man
movie yeah yeah you know and he's such a
major villain so maybe he doesn't
directly
appear in here but maybe we'll learn the
truth it's kind of like how
we don't see voldemort's full appearance
until like the fourth harry potter movie
but you know he's coming yeah but you
know he's coming
you know but you maybe you see his face
in some way or an iterative portal after
steppenwolf's head is decapitated oh
yeah that's my favorite
but yeah like you know the lay person
who doesn't follow this stuff doesn't
necessarily know kang so for a lot of
people it's still going to be a surprise
and yeah like
whereas mephisto could be one of many
explanations for the events or
some of the events of one division this
feels like someone has to be behind the
curtain
and it would make a lot of sense for it
to be yeah yeah and i'll also add lastly
i think it's really neat how because the
timekeepers are actual characters
in the in the marvel comics they're
either real characters or not
androids this doesn't seem to be
something that pissed people off
yeah like it worked within the context
and usually when marvel goes
not real yeah
get a trevor slattery like you get
situations like that but this was the
case where
people didn't seem actually pissed off
it seems that they seemed excited about
the possibility if it is
yeah which is kind of strange people are
just are not as attached to the
timekeeper characters
all right wizard of oz us but right as
loki is about to confess his love to
silvi rinslayer prunes him through the
back
just like how he got colson but i also
like how far
it seems like his heart is glowing out
of his voice and his is the last thing
to fade similar to how when visions
dated the last thing wanda solves
rhyming images with lyrics about love
eternal even when life is over
similar to how these two loki variants
have survived several apocalypses and
actually one shot in the credits has
been updated to include among the
photographs of loki and sylvia
photograph of sylvia's little young girl
then the post-credits scene where loki
awakens this is
hell now the captions reveal he is
spelling it with one
l meaning he's referring to the
afterlife of norse mythology not the
christian
crazy specific yes
so these are credited as classic loki
played by richard e grant
he's dressed up in the bright yellow and
green look from the comics maybe he's a
loki variant that was pruned from the
comic universe then boastful loki
who carries a version of mjolnir that
appears to be a truck piston
attached to a piece of train rail and
then kid look
oh so it's not male 1 so it's just a
knockout oh
man i'm gonna make a cooler wheel there
i thought i had a good theory there cold
sad crappy silver version crap that
really uh oh that bumps you out
maybe in that universe uh mjolnir is
just made of a piece of train track and
a truck piston
and then kid loki another character from
the comics who carries an
alligator with its own loki crown now
loki in the past has performed conjuring
with animals like snakes and frogs
actually the frog was itself a reference
to the throg comics but the voice we
heard was richard e grant
though it was off screen leading some
folks online to speculate that this
could have been the gator talking
i don't know about that i hope it's the
case though now they are in the ruins of
new york city you can see avengers tower
back there
and you could see this as the aftermath
of the battle of new york in which
either loki won or maybe where iron man
failed to divert that nuke you can
actually hear the orchestra notes that
are part of alan sivestry's avengers
theme
unless you come with us
but look closely at that particular
avengers tower that is not
the 2012 era stark tower which did not
yet have the upper quinjet landing pad
that was not added until the next time
we saw the tower in 2015's age of ultron
so
i am thinking this could be sometime
after 2018 after
the sacred timeline loki died because at
that point earth was in the afternoon
and then maybe the tva prunes all
variant loki's that they capture to this
exile timeline
to keep them from respawning in some
other place in time
and this could mean president loki and
the ragtag bunch around him
are all banished loki's who have gone
nutty in this prison
we'll explore this more as we go on to
damn what an episode of telling you we
just watched again you can support us by
checking out our merch options at
newarkstartsmerch.com you can follow me
on instagram and twitter at eavos follow
new rockstars subscribe to new rockstars
thanks for watching bye
i can't wait for the next i'm i'm like
insanely excited for the next steps next
two episodes are gonna be insane loki
into the loki verse
guys subscribe to nr if you haven't done
so already
as always fantastic breakdown i failed
john you got three this time this was
your video
i'd like to thank you all for coming
today
subscribe and we'll catch you guys soon
you